[Musik]
hola hola hola hola klassikers
bienvenido the spanish kommissars libyen
ja ja wir sprechen kein spanisch das war
nur ein kleiner scherz
guck mal ein richtiger schenkelklopfer
körper genau auf deutsch gesagt man ein
schenkelklopfer wenn der witz so lustig
war dass man sich vor spaß auf die
schenkel kraft ja es aber einen gewinn
von ihm zudem ein bisschen zudem als
echter schenkelklopfer war das ja also
ich fand es witzig die leute eher witzig
die hälfte der leute abgeschaltet
ja da sind wir ja gerade bei dem tollen
thema wir leben wir reden heute über das
leben in deutschland
dieses video ist nur auf deutsch heute
mal wieder wir machen einen live stream
wir werden ein bisschen über fragen
sprechen von euch zum thema leben in
deutschland und wir haben vorher einige
fragen gesammelt die wir heute
besprechen und ihr könnt auch live
fragen stellen und wir sind heute zu
viert man sieht nur zwei von uns
janoschka hallo hallo hola hola und wir
haben hinter den kulissen sind auch
francisco und manuel dabei die sich auch
um den chat kümmern ihr könnt also
jederzeit fragen stellen und wir werden
dann nicht alle fragen beantworten es
sind schon sehr viele gekommen aber wir
werden so viele fragen beantworten wie
möglich liegt die beiden kurz anschalten
einfach um hallo zu winken wie in die
ritzen die wir sonst nicht
[Gelächter]
ich freue mich sehr dass wir beide hier
sind
ich würde gerne die am anfang eine frage
stellen wann bist du nach deutschland
gekommen das ist noch nicht die frage
aber nur als hintergrund
das ist jetzt schon 36 jahre herne
das war eine frage also ja es am 14
august 1984 und das ist schon sehr lange
her viele von uns waren dort noch gar
nicht auf der welt viele von euch
zuschauern
ich würde dich gerne fragen janisch was
hattest du und das habe ich glaube ich
dich selber noch gar nicht richtig
gefragt was war dein bild von
deutschland bevor du nach deutschland
gekommen bist hattest du eigentlich
hattest du ein positives bild oder
negatives du wolltest ja gar nicht
unbedingt in deutschland bleiben oder
hattest du neutrales bild hat sich
deutschland gar nicht wirklich
interessiert ich habe gar kein kein bild
das ist wirklich schwer zu erzählen und
zu erklären
aber deutschland waren lag nie in meinem
interessenspektrum ich habe mich nie
über deutschland für deutschland
interessiert ist was nicht existent und
komischerweise und dafür schäme ich mich
bis heute weil das versehen naiv von mir
und und reis aber in der zeit wo ich
schon wusste dass ich nach deutschland
fliehen werde und dass ich in
deutschland wahrscheinlich zumindest nur
kurze zeit leben werde und ich hatte
sogar eine plakette mit münster so und
mit dem logo von ins all das klebte da
und ich freute mich und trotzdem bin ich
nicht darauf gekommen in einer
bibliothek zu gehen und mehreren buch
auszuleihen und über deutschland etwas
zu lesen einfach ja damals gab es ja
noch gar kein internet
nein und und bis bis ich versuche es mir
zu erklären weil ich war nicht so ich
war nicht so ganz domina und trotzdem
war das irgendwie nicht in meinen unfall
umfeld und wahrscheinlich weil ich viel
zu beschäftigt war vor allen dingen mit
dieser spannung wird mir die flucht
gelingen
klappt es heißt du und dann hast hast du
alles andere so auch später geschoben
erst mal wenn ich da bin
und wenn es klappt dann sehe ich sehe
ich weiter ja aber ich wusste nichts von
deutschland gar nichts so richtig
natürlich wusste ich dass man in
deutschland deutsch spricht und dass das
westdeutschland gibt und aus deutschland
aber dann dann und das ist berlin
und dann weiß eigentlich schon alles und
natürlich die zweite weltkrieg
geschichten das weiß ihr depot pohl aber
über das moderne leben in deutschland
wusste ich nicht und nicht nur das ich
bin zum beispiel nach deutschland
geflohen und dann als man mich gefragt
hat in deutschland na ja und warum
willst du bleiben bist du ein
politischer flüchtling oder kommt deine
familie waren vielleicht früher deutsche
staatsbürger
dann bin ich aus allen wolken gefallen
so aber jetzt jetzt muss ich mich darum
kümmern
aber ich glaube das war einfach diese
spannung war soll richtig dass das die
flucht ja vielleicht nicht gelingen
würde dass man sich mit den anderen
sachen nicht beschäftigt hat wird
interessant also nochmal als hintergrund
du bist 1984 aus polen nach deutschland
gekommen
du bist mit einer fähre eigentlich zum
einkaufen gefahren und dann aber
abgehauen und der als durfte man polen
nicht verlassen und dein plan war aber
gar nicht in deutschland zu bleiben
sondern in die usa weiter zu fliehen und
du bist dann allerdings für den rest des
bisherigen lebens in deutschland
geblieben
wir haben eine passende frage von saada
fund er hat geschrieben was findet
janisch besonders komisch in deutschland
was war denn damals als du dich dann so
langsam gewöhnt hat in deutschland
hattest du so eine art kulturschock
fandest du irgendwas wirklich merkwürdig
oder vermisst
erst mal alles toll also dass das am
anfang ganz schnell ich glaube schon am
zweiten tag
wir sind ja zu unserem freund gekommen
und deshalb hatten wir leute die sich um
mich und einen freund mit dem ich
zusammen kam gekümmert haben und so
hatten wir am zweiten tag schon fahre
damit denen sie gefahren sind
aber wir checkten noch nicht so ganz
dieses system mit fahrradwegen und nicht
fahrradwegen und irgendwann hätten wir
beinahe eine gruppe von münchen
umgefahren und die stadt mit uns zu
schimpften lachten und winkten und und
hh reagierten völlig entspannt und ich
dachte wow endlich bin ich in der welt
in der ich auch bleiben will ja also du
hast die deutschen freund nicht
wahrgenommen absolut und ist absolut
überraschend freundlich und und lieb und
und ja ich habe mich sehr schnell in die
deutschen als nicht in die menschen die
ich getroffen habe jeden tag graf
verliebt will ich auch jetzt vielleicht
nicht so große wörter in den mund nehmen
aber ich mochte sie ich mochte diese
alltagskultur in deutschland total und
so vor
das überrascht nicht weil deutschland
ist ja auch dafür bekannt dass die leute
sehr unfreundlich sind sehr schroff sehr
direkt und ich muss sagen mir fällt das
immer dann auf wenn ich in ein anderes
land fahre in dem die leute viel
freundlicher auf der straße sind wie
heiß sie nicht spanien die usa
der arabische länder in denen ich war
alle afrikanischen länder in denen ich
war da gibt es so eine herzlichkeit auf
der straße und auch so nah am alltag und
an deutschland denke ich immer die leute
sind so wer aber wie du weißt komme ich
nicht aus spanien oder nicht aus den
freundlichen arabischen staaten sondern
ich kümmert den kalten und
unfreundlichen polen und so und so sind
unsere perspektiven völlig anders ja in
polen lächelt
schon schon gar nicht ihn damals in den
ganz schweren symbolen zeiten hatte ich
keine angelächelt und keine begrüßt und
alle waren richtig schnell mit die
nerven überfordert wenn etwas passiert
ist und leute prügelten sich in den
langen schlangen denen sie jeden tag
steirisch erstehen mussten und ich bekam
zum ersten mal damals kopfhörer mit den
ich musik hören könnte beim gehen und
ich war ganz froh sich die musik hören
kann und die leute in mir gar nicht
angucken brauchte ja da soll ich was los
es gab schon ein grund dass sich polen
verlassen und bis heute in russland wenn
du bist heute wenn du einen russischen
menschenschlag so alvi gilt dann sagte
er mir sagst du nur um nichts nichts
nichts besonders
okay dass dieses vorurteil wollen wir
mal von unseren russischen
zuschauerinnen und zuschauern bestätigen
lassen oder nicht bestätigen lassen ihr
könnt uns jetzt einen kommentar
schreiben
denn jannis du warst du auch noch nie in
polen er in russland bevor wir jetzt
hier
die vorurteile über russland raus und
das stimmt absolut aber ich habe ja nein
das stimmt absolut dass ist ein reinster
vorurteil den ich habe meistens von den
russen selbst erzählt ja raba thema
vorurteile chris kelly chris kelly co
schreibt hast du selber schon und herr
vorurteilen in deutschland gelitten also
sind menschen dir mit vorurteilen
begegnet weil du aus polen kommst ja
aber da müssen wir schon wieder von der
perspektive sprechen ja also ich bin aus
polen hierhergekommen und
ich habe hier eine entspannte um
lächelnde unfreundliche gesellschaft
angetroffen und natürlich fanden sich
immer wieder irgendwelche idioten
darunter aber nochmal ich komme aus
einer gesellschaft ist auch nicht am
idioten mangelt und so wusste ich ich
hatte nie diese erwartung die deutsche
gesellschaft muss perfekt sein und alle
müssen jetzt freundlich sein natürlich
erwartest du dass es auch leute gibt die
einfach bescheuert sind und mit
englischen bescheuerten sachen ankommen
und du bist frau dass nun zumindest sie
marginalisieren kannst ja und das ist in
deutschland der fall ist
ja ich fahre ich traf leute die mehr
gegenüber unfreundlich waren
wahrscheinlich nur weil ich ausländer
oder weil ich pole war aber ich hab das
ja in dem sinne verstanden dass ich
dachte hey wenn du als deutsche in polen
leben würdest du hättest du
wahrscheinlich es noch schwieriger als
ich jeden deutschland ja kein
schwieriges thema aber grundsätzlich was
würdest du menschen raten wenn sie nach
deutschland kommen und vielleicht angst
haben dass es vorurteile gibt ja ich
habe ein ratschlag den allerersten kommt
nach deutschland kommt alle hierher
es lohnt ist das leben in deutschland
ist wirklich erträglich und hat
perspektiven hat energie natürlich
braucht jeder von uns noch ganz
persönlichen glück und und viele leute
sind hier wahrscheinlich genauso viele
leute sind in deutschland unglücklich
wie in jedem anderen nahm man sagt dass
die diese statistik des glücks ist
ungefähr gleich in allen ländern
aber in deutschland ist ein sehr
angenehmes land ein sehr angenehmes lag
nicht hundertprozentig weil das wollen
wir ja noch nicht erwarten lässt dass er
dabei
bei bestem willen nicht also janisch
empfiehlt nach deutschland zu kommen
da passt mein nächstes thema und zwar
ist das orte in deutschland uns haben
sehr viele leute geschrieben
die fragen gestellt haben zu den
verschiedenen orten und eine frage ist
zum beispiel wo wird es du wohnen wenn
du jetzt nach deutschland kommt um
deutsch zu lernen was ist eine gute ein
guter ort und jeff hat uns zum beispiel
auf bachelor geschrieben
kennt ihr einen könnt ihr ein dorf in
deutschland empfehlen wo es wenige
englisch sprechende leute gibt nein das
kennen das kennen wir nicht weil
eigentlich englisch ist in deutschland
nicht nur zwei nicht nur die
fremdsprache die menschen sprechen
sondern diese fremdsprache ist schon
fast ein stückchen näher es ist auch
eine zweitsprache geworden
bei vielen oder also leute schalten ins
englische sofort um wenn sie manchmal
nummer in akzent hören ja ja aber nicht
also ich würde sagen das machen junge
leute und leute die in der großen stadt
sind also die menschen die nach berlin
ziehen
auch aus deutschland die ziehen nach
berlin weil es eine internationale stadt
ist die rechnen damit dass sie hier
menschen aus der ganzen welt treffen
aber wenn du in der kleinen stadt bist
oder in dem dorf da rechnet keiner damit
dass du auf englisch spricht und die
leute erwarten dass du deutsch sprichst
deswegen würde ich schon empfehlen wenn
du unbedingt schnell deutsch lernen
möchtest kommen nicht nach berlin das
hört sich zwar doof an weil berlin ist
für mich wirklich auch die angenehmste
stadt in deutschland aber hier ist es
wirklich schwierig wenn du hier studiert
hier arbeitest ist es sehr
wahrscheinlich dass du auf englisch
viele freunde trifft auf dass du auf
englisch arbeit ist und es wird
schwierig und sonst darf ich die meiner
lieblingsstädte in deutschland nun ja da
gibt es nämlich auch noch eine frage zu
rio fragt wo in deutschland außer berlin
würdet ihr wohnen und es gab auch
tatsächlich eine frage hier unten
zum thema lieblingsstädte was sind deine
lieblings städte und einfach bei mir die
üblichen aber ich würde gerne in münster
wurden
ich habe ihn schon 30 jahre gewohnt aber
ich liebe münster immer noch und wenn
jemand diese diesen chaos und und
hässlichkeit eine großen staat nicht mag
er soll nach münster nach münster fahren
es gibt aber auch sehr viele andere
städte deutsche städte von dieser größe
den ausdruck zum beispiel freiburg
bremen ganz viele städte die die klein
und mit einer unglaublichen charakter da
kommen und wunderschön sind ja es gibt
auch eine frage von marie sie fragt was
bedeutet für dich janisch heimat ist die
also das hat sie nicht geschrieben sie
schreibt nur was bedeutet für dich
heimat ist deine heimat deutschland oder
polen oder beides polen ist nicht nicht
mehr meine heimat und deutschland essen
ich meine heimat und in dem sinne ist
meine heimat ist vielleicht lächerlich
wie es klingt aber meine heimat ist das
internet das internet
mein herz oder das was ich mache meine
nachbarschaft meine straße das ist
wirklich meine meine heimat darf da
fühle ich mich zu hause das ist auch der
grund warum ich in berlin mich so gut
fühle als ich nach berlin kam dachte ich
wow das ist meine heimat hier ist meine
heimat polen ist mit mittlerweile so
fremd geworden so anders geworden
meine zeiten sind diese kommunistischen
zeiten
die gibt es nicht mehr in wollen münster
wiederum war einfach viel zu schön um
wahr zu sein
und berlin ist ja hier bin ich zu hause
also für mich selber ist das so dass ich
tatsächlich mittlerweile merke wir waren
ja
jetzt in münster wir kommen aus münster
eine stadt mit 300.000 einwohnern
ungefähr und natürlich jetzt über
weihnachten in der kroner zeit ist es
dort gar nichts los ist es natürlich im
sommer ohne corona ist es super nett ist
es viel los aber es ist eben klein und
das ist anders als ganz anders als
berlin
und ich muss sagen dass ich mittlerweile
ist berlin so ein bisschen meine heimat
ich freue mich zurück zu kommen in
dieser stadt wo auch vieles ein bisschen
anonym ist vieles ein bisschen verrückt
ist und ich bin sehr gerne hier in
berlin und die einst die anderen städte
die ich mir noch vorstellen könnte zu
leben oder eine stadt wo ich mir gut
vorstellen könnt ihr zu leben ist köln
einfach weil ich da auch oft war es gibt
noch einige andere große städte in
deutschland mit denen ich aber keinen
persönlichen zugabe wie hamburg bremen
finde ich auch sehr nett ja ich glaube
ich würde in eine größere stadt ziehen
aber zum deutschland ist manchmal eine
kleinere gut janisch wir haben auch noch
einige fragen bekommen zu uns persönlich
zu dir und zu mir und zwar die häufigste
frage die hier gestellt wird ist kari
die prüfer krombacher oder warsteiner
nein das hat nur einer geschrieben
nämlich paco ich trinke beides nicht ich
trinke protein freies bier die andere
die heuft die tatsächlich häufigste
frage ist seit ihr verheiratet
organisch bist du mit mir verheiratet
ja ich bin mit dir sehr glücklich schon
seit zehn jahren verheiratet
toll da hätten wir das auch beantwortet
die andere frage ist wie haben wir uns
kennengelernt
wir haben uns tatsächlich in einem
medienhaus kennengelernt in münster
dort haben wir videos produziert janisch
hat dort ein magazin produziert an dem
ich dann
ich habe gar nicht mehr so viel damit
gearbeitet wir haben dann zusammen ein
magazin produziert das war ein
musikmagazin in einem lokalen
fernsehsender
aber da konnte man selber fernsehen
machen also wir waren
amateure janosch wie ist denn das
fernsehmagazin was du damals produziert
hast vor allen dingen unsere magazin
hieß auto complete ja ich meine aber
dass deutsch polnischer kultur magazin
das hatte so einen tollen namen unter
freunden ist das nicht trans forum tv
löhne unter freunden transform tv auch
aber das war nur diese deutsch polnische
club aber das programm das sich
produziert habe quasi an dem da soll
sich ausländer und deutsche
zusammenkommen hieß unter freunden und
den titel habe ich mir selber ausgedacht
habe weil ich mich unter deutschen immer
als unter freunden gefühlt und begriffen
und da merkte ich aber dass viele leute
das gar nicht so optimistisch hören
wollen dass sie wollen lieber so ja
verfolgte ausland in münster oder so
echt ja ich war ich gerade immer oder
ich bin erfüllt unseren optimismus und
freude reste und manchmal die leute die
politisch interessiert sind sagen sie ja
ja ja so schön es ist aber nicht ja wir
haben auch unsere probleme was auch
stimmt dass wir dich würde ich auch
zustimmen jan als diese frage finde ich
sehr interessant sind schreibt können
sie wovon können sie uns in deutschland
ab raten was würdest du in deutschland
auf keinen fall machen
ich würde auf keinen fall drogen kaufen
zum beispiel war weil es ist weder in
deutschland noch irgendwo anders gut
ich würde auch mit ich weiß jetzt nicht
sonst gefällt mir ich würde nicht klar
zum beispiel weil das sehr schlecht
angesehen ist
leute mögen das nicht ich würde
vorsichtig fahrrad fahren weil die die
leute gehen mit mit miteinander hier
sehr lieb um und wenn jemand dazu
aggressiv ist dann fällt das unangenehm
auf es gibt auch ein zwei fragen dazu
von leuten die vielleicht angst haben
dass sie in deutschland auch
rassistische erfahrungen machen wir
haben gerade schon über vorurteile
gesprochen
zum beispiel hat sarah die geschrieben
wie rassistisch ist deutschland
besonders in kleinen städten
er schreibt auch ich habe angst davor
ich weiß es nicht ich habe diese
erfahrungen nicht ja weil ich bin ein
pole aber von außen sehe ich wie ein
weißer alter mann und ich falle da nicht
sonderlich auf aber sonst aber soll
schwarze lass mich sonst ist es immer so
jemand der rassistisch ist der gibt
zeugen ist ein schwachsinniger mensch zu
sein und dann müssen wir natürlich uns
vor vorsehen und traurig sein und ihm in
bemitleiden
aber wir dürfen uns nicht von diesen
menschen uns von diesen menschen
schrecken einjagen ja und wirklich es
gibt es ist die mehrheit von menschen
die absolute mehrheit von menschen die
absolut normal für mich ist jemand der
ein rassist ist
der ist krank im kopf weil
wahrscheinlich weil er zu wenig
gehirnzellen hat und das ist keine
mehrheit hier in deutschland und wir
müssen einfach stark stehen und manchmal
die dagegen ankämpfen
und manchmal ist diese starke position
einfach sich nicht fertigmachen zu
lassen zu sagen okay ja ich weiß es gibt
es gibt schon leute die dummen sind
schade es tut weh aber was willst du
aber das darfst du nicht projizieren auf
die ganze gesellschaft weil so ist es
nicht das hat sich deutschland nicht
verdient
ja ja das ist auch gut zu wissen als ich
meinen wir können nicht lügen und sagen
deutschland dessen perfektes in
deutschland ist auch scheiße und hat
scheiß seiten
und natürlich gibt es auch rassismus in
deutschland aber ist ändert sich auch
viel das muss man auch sagen es hat sehr
lange zeit gedauert auch es wird noch
viele jahrzehnte dauern bis deutschland
wirklich sage ich mal eine volle voll
akzeptierte multikulturelle gesellschaft
ist aber das wird jetzt schon mit den
kindern die jetzt aufwachsen
die werden schon in 30 und in 50 jahren
anders leben als wir das jetzt tun man
muss auch sagen meine eltern zum
beispiel die sind zur schule gegangen
und da gab es in der schule meistens
blonde kinder und da war der große
unterschied bist du katholisch oder
evangelisch und darüber haben sich die
leute gestritten
und bei mir in der schulzeit sei es
schon ein bisschen anders aus und jetzt
in der schulzeit ist es doch wieder
anders und es wachsen neue generationen
auf und ich würde auch vertrauen darin
haben dass die sachen besser werden aber
man muss auch damit rechnen dass es
immer noch leute gibt die ja nicht mit
internationalen menschen aus menschen
aus anderen ländern aufgewachsen sind
und vielleicht auch vorurteile haben zum
wäsche schreibt uns junis ich habe eine
frage wie offen sind deutsche
unternehmen für andere kulturen oder
religionen darf eine frau in einer
deutschen firma ihr kopftuch tragen zum
beispiel ich glaube das hängt auch stark
davon ab wo du bist ich glaube ein
kopftuchverbot gibt es nirgendwo in
deutschland und ich denke auch dass
keine firma das verbieten kann
aber es ist natürlich eine frage wie die
leute drauf sind und das wird man dann
schon bei der bewerbung merken und ich
denke also ich weiß dass leider von
vielen von vielen
jungen frauen die ich kennengelernt habe
dass sie schlechte erfahrungen gemacht
haben leider bei der bewerbung mit einem
kopftuch aber ich würde es trotzdem
probieren und es gibt auf jeden fall
genug firmen die offen sind und dann
wenn sie wenn du dann an der richtigen
firma bist bist du auch eine ganz
normale gute zeit haben also es ist ja
kann man nicht sagen dass es das eine
oder das andere gibt es gibt
wahrscheinlich alles in deutschland
janosch jannis es gibt eine frage wie
lange hast du gebraucht um fließend
deutsch zu sprechen das haben wir letzte
mal schon ein bisschen bequatscht ich
dachte schon glaube ich nach vier jahren
dass ich ziemlich fließend deutsch
spreche
eine lange zeit naja also eine sprache
fließend sprechen zu lernen das nimmt
schon einige zeit
es gibt leute die viel talentierter sind
als ich wir haben ja selber leute die
kosten die ein jahr deutsch gelernt
haben und fließend mit uns gesprochen
haben dass es richtig ab aber das sind
die top leute die leute die irgendwie
fleiß haben und talent haben und ich bin
einfach absolut durchschnittlicher
mensch dann nach vier jahren diese ja
diese fließen
diese fähigkeit wissen zu sprechen
erlangt hat und das war auch die zeit wo
ich überlegt habe ob ich jetzt nur noch
deutsch spreche oder kombiniere ich war
in zwei sprachen und ich habe mich für
zweisprachigkeit entschieden sogar
dreisprachigkeit mittlere weile weil
diese dreisprachigkeit entstand ist
etwas als wir im internet angefangen
haben jeden tag englisch mitmenschen zu
schreiben und zu kommunizieren
aber damals dachte ich soll ich jetzt
nur deutsch sprechen das wäre gar keine
falsche entscheidung weil ich würde mit
sicherheit besser gold sprechen jetzt ja
aber ich liebe polnisch spanisch ist
meine muttersprache
ich bin überhaupt nicht ein nationalist
oder so ich habe auch probleme meine
probleme mit uns jeder pole hat probleme
mit polen
aber es ist quasi meine sprache die die
ganz tief eingebrannt ist in mein gehirn
und ich liebe diese sprache und bleibe
mit dieser sprache und ich lebe in den
beiden sprachen doppel tops wir hatten
auch eine frage auf polnisch soll ich
mal versuchen die vorzulesen ob branche
bei einer diät allerdings nie sonja grau
3d jemand freut sich denn sagt addiert
die ich vorgestellt habe gefällt ihm vor
allen dingen diese verknüpfung mit dem
spiel in der virtuellen realität hat das
war keine frage aber in einem kommentar
auf freuen ist hier sarah hat hier eine
super frage seid ihr in der gleichen
wohnung aber in getrennten zimmern
ja ich glaube das ist der grund warum
wir so glücklich sind weil wir so
ziemlich ziemlich unkonventionell sind
und das fällt uns eigentlich das fiel
uns selber es sehr viel später ein
aber vom anfang an machten wir gerne zb
getrennt essen und dabei internet gucken
was wahrscheinlich die meisten die
meisten menschen als völlig a sie
empfinden ja aber richtig
manche menschen finden das komisch wenn
man nicht zusammen ist dazu passt die
frage von nasir teil
ich hoffe ich spreche das richtig aus
abendbrot oder abendessen
ihr wisst dass ich dieses diät mache
deshalb ist das abendbrot aber gerade
jetzt mag anlässen abendessen ein brot
ist ja nicht blöd zum abend oder nein
doch jetzt ja weil ich die kleinen pause
mache und ich geniesse in abendrot finde
ich lecker und wenn ich unter 100 kilo
wiege werde jeden tag abendbrot essen
aber wegen wegen meine diät ist das
abendessen also die super die ich acht
mal am tage ist ja das konnte ja sehen
im video letzte woche am sonntag wie
janisch diät macht und was er ist es ist
tatsächlich eine deutsche eine deutsche
tradition dass man abends abendbrot ist
ich weiß gar nicht macht man das in
polen auch in polen ist man ja ausgelöst
wird
aber ist du nicht abends dann auch eine
suppe oder was warmes holen ist sehr
sehr ähnlich zu deutschland überraschend
ähnlich obwohl russland auch glaube ich
nenne diese tradition dass man abends
brot und dann ein bisschen fleisch ein
bisschen wurst ein bisschen käse
vielleicht noch ein paar andere gurken
solche sachen das ist irgendwie deutsch
polnisch sind zentraleuropäischen das
ist witzig also ich glaube in vielen
anderen ländern
ich weiß dass ich weiß es einfach von
vielen menschen die nach deutschland
kommen
die sagen diese tradition dass man
abends brot isst und morgens auch roth
ist wie die leute völlig verrückt das
haben wir jetzt noch gerade mit jeremy
diskutiert liebe grüße falls du uns erst
er war jetzt vier wochen im krankenhaus
in deutschland ist jetzt gott sei dank
wieder raus und hat dort morgens und
abends brot bekommen und er hat sich
sehr massiv darüber beschwert und
irgendwann habe ich ihm erzählt hey das
ist aber nicht nur typisches krankenhaus
essen sondern viele menschen essen
abends abendbrot deswegen habe ich
dieses wort abendbrot ich habe auch in
meiner familie abends immer nur
brot gegessen und als ich ihm das gesagt
habe da war er richtig geschockt und
meinte so mein gott deswegen sind die
deutschen immer so schlecht drauf
green ist brot einfach kein
substanzieller essens bestandteil sind
da ist nichts substanzielles drin das
sind nur kohlenhydrate ja nicht weil ich
hab ja da ich jetzt meine zeit diese
pause zeit genieße ich habe mir eine
gurke gekauft eine eine frühstücks gurke
also soll man dann habe ich mir tomaten
gekauft und zwiebel und es braucht aber
auch mit viel gemüse darauf dass wir
werden gleich aufhören ich möchte noch
ein zwei sachen über ein zwei kleine
themen sprechen
morgen ist silvester das ist ja der
letzte tag im jahr
einige leute fragen dazu wie wir dieses
jahr das neue jahr feiern und es gibt
auch einige fragen dazu wie überhaupt
das leben in deutschland während der
korona zeit ist vielleicht ist das ein
ganz gutes beispiel wie feiern wir dann
morgen jannes ja ganz anders also ganz
chor ohne rippas und der einzige mensch
der sich wahrscheinlich darüber freut
bin ich es entweder weil ich habe
tatsächlich in polen oft silvester
alleine oder nun recht gefeiert ja sehr
oft und ich fand das toll ich fand das
so ich fange ich empfand den silvester
als meine meinen privaten feier feiertag
bräuchten eine das alte jahr
verabschiedet und in dieses neue jahr
rein gehe und zum beispiel als junger
mann habe ich hier bodybuilding
trainiert und da möchte ich zum zb zwei
minuten vor dem neuen jahr mich auf
diese bank hinzulegen und die gewichte
zu stemmen war sie bis das neue jahr als
diese motivation training für das nur ja
ja
und das neue jahr war für mich immer so
die zeigt es das nachdenken und es
überlegen wie ist es gelaufen was willst
du besser machen
wie wirst du dein leben gestalten und
bis heute wenn ich die leute sehe die
dann sich besaufen und und knapp feuern
dann dächten denke ich die leute
okay es ist interessant ja ich für mich
ist das auch auf jeden fall eine zeit in
der ich viel darüber nachdenke was
letztes jahr passiert ist was ich
nächstes jahr machen möchte john hat uns
dazu eine schöne frage geschrieben was
sind eure ziele für easy german für das
nächste jahr wir haben tatsächlich viele
ziele und ich freue mich diese zeit auch
so ein bisschen mit mir selbst zu
verbringen und dieses jahr ist es
tatsächlich anders also normalerweise
ich habe immer silvesterparty und ich
finde sogar es war immer stressig
silvester zu organisieren weil viele
leute haben diese erwartung dass man
silvester die größte und beste party
haben muss oder dass man irgendwo
besonders hinfahren möchte also wir
haben glaube ich wochen und monate damit
verbracht meine freunde und ich dass wir
versucht haben einen gemeinsamen trip
einen gemeinsamen trip zu planen über
silvester und das hat er nicht geklappt
weil man muss das früh genug planen und
so weiter und irgendwie fand ich diese
großen erwartungen an die silvester
pläne immer ein bisschen stressig in den
letzten jahren und ich bin auch sehr
froh dass wir einfach morgen gar nicht
feiern können also es ist in deutschland
wird alles versucht damit die leute
nicht so sehr feiern man darf sich nur
mit maximal zwei haushalten treffen
man darf nichts dollar kaufen um man
darf die also wenn man schon welche hat
darf man die benutzten deswegen bin ich
selber gespannt wie das morgen ist ob
berlin aussieht wie normalerweise berlin
ist ja normalerweise an silvester ein
wie im
also wie im krieg das ist ja richtig
teilweise richtig verstörend und
schrecklich dass alle leute auf der
straße sind und böller und raketen
zünden
und ich hoffe das ist morgen anders wird
dass es ruhiger wird es gibt auch ein
alkoholverbot es gibt ein böllerverbot
an vielen orten und wir werden morgen
abend auch mal ein bisschen unser plan
ist dass wir ein bisschen spazieren
gehen und rum fahren und gucken wusste
so zum beispiel ja nicht dass der
mauerpark komplett gesperrt ist morgen
es gibt sogar ein aufenthaltsverbot
nicht nur ein böllerverbot
ja sie versuchen die menschenmenge zu
zerstreuen und ich finde das auch
richtig also wir müssen tatsächlich als
gesellschaft jetzt an einem strang
ziehen und das ist so sehr dass sie so
einsichtig dass ich mit mir danke keine
neben verschwörungstheorien denke bis zu
zehn jahren
die krankheit ist da und ja wir müssen
sie eindämmen und jahr china und vietnam
und andere länder wo die gesellschaften
sehr diszipliniert sind haben das
überwunden
also lassen als auch noch nicht aber es
ist dort anders als in deutschland ja in
deutschland sind die zahlen leider im
moment nicht so gut wir werden noch viel
zeit zu hause verbringen müssen und ich
hoffe auch dass viele leute zu hause
bleiben denn das ist im moment das
richtige und kommen wir noch mal zu den
plänen einige leute schreiben was wir
für pläne haben junis schreibt auch was
sind die projekte die in der pipeline
sind für easy german und fürs nächste
jahr
wir haben wirklich viele pläne also mit
ziel eng werden wir jetzt ganz intensiv
daran arbeiten und uns sehr stark darauf
fokussieren dass die app endlich
rauskommt die hatten wir letztes jahr
schon angekündigt und auch aufgrund von
der krankheit von jeremy hat sich das
jetzt verzögert und wir werden die
hoffentlich sehr bald in die app stores
bringen und bei easyjet haben wir auch
einige pläne und wir hoffen sehr darauf
dass wir ab dem sommer und vielleicht
auch ab dem herbst irgendwann wieder
reisen können und auch mit applaus
diese können einige leute haben uns
geschrieben wie zb afonso
wann ist wieder mit ups geben wird und
wir hoffen dass wir euch treffen können
vielleicht ab sommer oder ab herbst auch
wieder in größeren gruppen vielleicht
auch mal zu einem podcast live das würde
uns sehr freuen
das ist ein traum von manuela das sind
alles so kleine pläne die wir haben und
jetzt zum abschied möchte ich euch noch
empfehlen dass wir morgen einen ganz
besonderen eine ganz besondere podcast
episode herausbringen und zwar könnt ihr
die finden auf german fm und in allen
podcast eps um 11 uhr morgen früh am 31
dezember kommt unser großes silvester
spezial und janisch manuel easy und ich
werden zu viert silvester mit euch
feiern und auf das jahr zurückblicken
und dort auch über unsere pläne für das
nächste jahr sprechen also wenn ihr mehr
von uns hören wollt und auch mit uns
feiern wollt ihr könnt das auch hören
während ihr zuhause alleine feiert dann
seid ihr einfach mit uns morgen und wir
freuen uns darauf sie german punkt fm
und zum abschied möchten recht natürlich
noch einladen ein mitglied zu werden von
easy german damit unterstützt die unsere
arbeit und ihr bekommt auch was dafür
nämlich interaktive übungen transkripte
und auch die transkripte zu unserem
podcast und vieles mehr
schaut euch das mal an auf katrin dot
org / wie sie dämmen janosch das können
wir noch mal machen oder unser letzter
livestream dieses jahr dieses video das
ist unser letztes video dieses jahr was
möchtest du der menschheit noch
mitteilen
lernt deutsch lernt weiter deutsch und
glaubt daran dass eure träume wahr
werden denn irgendwann werden wir alle
wieder reisen können ihr werdet nach
deutschland kommen können die von euch
die das schon lange planen und
vielleicht dieses jahr verschieben
müssen
es kann nur besser werden und es wird
auch besser daran glauben wir ganz fest
bleibt gesund oder werdet gesund
und wir sehen uns nächstes jahr toller
spruch zum ende ja toll was ihr da seid
ja liebe leute danach mailand francisco
manuel für die hilfe und dank an all
eure fragen ciao ciao